[Musique]
sur les rives du Châtelard la capitale
économique du sudiraquien officiellement
elle abrite 2 millions d'habitants mais
les contenus sont pas bons année après
année ces quartiers informels grignotent
les terrains en friche au rythme de la
flux de déplacer la désertification des
terres alentours pousse les agriculteurs
vers les villes
comme Mohamed 30 ans originaire d'un
village à l'est de Bassora arrivée en
2016 il connaît bien ses ruelles
[Musique]
le terrain appartient à l'État mais nous
nous sommes installés avons construit
légalement
nous avons utilisé des parpaings et de
la ferraille mais nous souffrons du
manque d'électricité et de services
publics
illégal de ces constructions les
disqualifie aux yeux des autorités pour
un raccordement réseau public alors ils
se sont débrouillés
l'eau que nous utilisons pour boire nous
la détournons du réseau public de la
ville avec ses tuyaux verts que nous
raccordons nous prenons l'électricité en
nous branchant au réseau public
principal
son oncle et sa famille l'ont rejoint
ici récemment
ensemble il lui en construit cette
maison deux briquets de broc fallait 50
ans aura tenté jusqu'au bout de rester
sur ses terres mais avec la baisse du
niveau de la rivière châteller arabe
l'eau salée du Golfe Persique c'est un
filtré et a eu raison de ses cultures
c'est à tout tué nous pouvions-nous
aller on ne pouvait pas souffrir une
grande maison donc nous nous sommes
installés dans ce quartier informel
les deux hommes dépendent à présent
d'emploi journaliers très aléatoire
et parfois on ne trouve pas parce que
nous sommes illettrés nous ne pouvons
pas travailler dans le secteur public
avec un revenu compris entre 13 et 17
euros par jour ils sont peu d'espoir de
sortir de ces quartiers mais la crainte
principale reste l'expulsion dont ils
sont menacés par les autorités locales
le gouverneur a estime que plus de 350
000 personnes vivent dans les quartiers
informels ils les tiennent pour
responsable des problèmes de gestion des
ressources dans la ville
on va arriver à saturation dans les
écoles il y aura trop de pression sur
les établissements de santé et des
embouteillages dans les rues il y aura
toujours plus de consommation d'énergie
d'eau et une saturation du réseau
d'évacuation des eaux usées cela va
affecter les services publics
sa voix un peu dépassée par le flux de
déplacer le gouvernorat a sur chercher
des solutions
les familles ne peuvent pas être jetées
à la rue on les dédommage avec une somme
d'argent ou un bout de terrain s'ils
sont originaires du gouvernorat s'ils
viennent d'ailleurs ils sont renvoyés
dans leur province d'origine
les autorités n'annoncent pas de mon
temps mais les habitants affirment que
le dédommagement s'élève à 3 millions de
dinars irakiens moins de 2000 euros
lorsque les maisons sont rasées comme
pour construire cette route Hassan vit
toujours dans sa ferme mais pas tous les
jours par ici pour se rendre sur les
chantiers de Bassora la situation le met
en colère
le gouvernement a de l'argent il allait
ressources il a le pétrole donc où va
l'argent
depuis la pandémie 40% de la population
de la province vit sous le seuil de
pauvreté Hassan tente de conserver ses
terres pour éviter de rejoindre à son
tour les bidonvilles mais plus rien ne
pousse et l'aide ne vient pas
même les canaux ont besoin d'être
entretenus et nettoyés par le ministère
de l'irrigation mais ça n'arrive pas où
les agriculteurs devraient-ils prendre
leur eau devons-nous creuser des puits
comme avant
depuis par milliers risquerait
d'assécher les nappes phréatiques dont
les réserves sont déjà peu renouvelées
une autre solution la désalinisation la
station d'abouracib inaugurée l'an
dernier traite 3000 mètres cubes d'eau
par jour et fait la fierté du
gouvernorat qui voudrait un projet
similaire à l'embouchure du Châtel arabe
c'est un projet stratégique parce que
c'est une solution radicale pour
préserver les eaux du Châtel arabe il
dépendra de la mer du Golfe qui est
stable nous pourrons y travailler et les
tendres à l'avenir
mais ces projets coûtent cher et seront
en priorité destinées à l'usage
domestique en l'absence de mesures
radicales pour ralentir cet exode rural
les organisations internationales
alertes sur les violences qui pourraient
éclater dans les villes en tension